Well, hello everyone. Can you hear me well? Okay.
Well, thank you for coming to our session
on modernizing non-clinical safety assessment in oncology
drug development.
I am Haleh Saber, division director in the Division
of Hematology, Oncology, Toxicology, or DHOT for
short,
in the oncology office at CDER FDA.
You might ask why we're having this session today.
That's because since last year, we are getting a lot of questions from the
sponsors about non-clinical studies that they need to conduct.
And why are we getting all these questions?
Because there was an FDA news last year, April
of 2025,
the announcement to phase out animal testing in drug development.
And that news was associated with a
roadmap,
and the roadmap mentioned stepwise reduction
in animal testing, starting with antibodies and with
an emphasis on use of new approach
methodologies or NAMs.
So that resulted in some confusions and we were getting a lot of,
not just us, but various review divisions at the FDA were getting
questions on what to do with the studies that are ongoing, or
we were getting pre-INDs with questions on do they need to
do any animal testing. So while that came as a surprise
to many in the field,
we in DHOT had already started and were
thinking about it over a decade ago.
So we started looking at
our data,
check what are the redundant studies,
can we reduce animal testing and make drug development
more efficient. We published
our research. We wrote oncology specific guidances.
So we were thinking about it a decade ago, and we still think
about it today. So one of the presentations will
have a glimpse into the future as to our pilots that we
are thinking about, and we would like to have your feedback
after that presentation.
So today we will have three presentations from
the FDA. The first one would be summary of what
we do in our division, DHOT, summary of the
streamlined
approaches we take in oncology.
The second one would be emphasis
on use of NAMs, new approach methodologies, and how we use
that, again, in oncology drug development.
And the third talk is about our
bioinformatic units in our division again, and again,
a glimpse into the future of what we are thinking.
We are constantly thinking about various pilots
and making drug development more efficient.
After the three presentations, we'll have a panel discussion,
and I encourage
the audience to come to the microphone, ask your questions,
and engage in the discussion.
With that, I would like to introduce the
speakers and the panelists. I will mention your names
and affiliation based on the order that I have.
Then I'll ask everyone to introduce yourself, one minute.
From the FDA, we have the speakers Michael Manning,
Natalie Simpson, and Matthew Thompson.
From the FDA, we have the panelist Tiffany Ricks.
And
non-FDA, we have the panelist
Jacinta Schenton from Amgen.
We have Shannon Mumenthaler from USC, and
Rodney Proel from Genentech. So starting from
this end, we start please. Michael, go ahead.
Yes. My name is Michael Manning. I'm a non-clinical reviewer at the
Division of Hematology, Oncology, Toxicology at the FDA.
Please.
I'm Natalie Simpson.
I am a lead toxicologist in the Division of Hematology,
Oncology, Toxicology at FDA.
Matthew Thompson, supervisory pharmacologist and acting
associate director for non-clinical bioinformatics in the
Oncology Center of Excellence.
I've been at FDA since
2015, and I'm very excited to share some of the
work we've been doing in bioinformatics.
I'm Tiffany Ricks. I'm the acting deputy division director
in DHOT and also a supervisory pharmacologist.
I'm overseeing a team of non-clinical reviewers, and I'm also
looking forward to the discussion about our future directions.
Hi, I'm Jacinta Schenton. Currently, I lead a team
at Amgen in Translational Safety and Risk
Sciences. My team supports
establishing the non-clinical strategy for all the drug development
programs. We also develop in vitro and in
silico methods to answer non-clinical safety questions.
Outside of Amgen, I'm also involved in cross-industry
consortia.
So last year, we published a paper through Bio
on leveraging new
approach
methodologies for regulatory filings for non-clinical safety,
and currently I'm involved through Pharma in drafting an
ICH reflection paper on NAMs
So I'm super excited to be here today to participate in this discussion, and thank
you to Hale for the invitation.
Great.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Shannon Mumenthaler.
I'm the Chief Translational Research Officer at the Ellison Medical Institute and
also faculty at USC.
My work really is at the intersection of translational science and
systems biology, with a focus on oncology drug development and
advancing more predictive human relevant model systems.
Good afternoon. I'm Rod Prell. I'm from Genentech, where I headed
the non-clinical safety for the oncology portfolio,
which encompasses large molecules, small molecules, ADCs, macrocycles,
whatever you can throw at oncology.
I've also been involved in cross-industry consortia with new approaches,
and am excited to be here because I think this is a really big topic for the
future as we move forward in non-clinical development.
Thank you. So with that, we can start with our first presentation.
Michael?
Thank you, Hale.
Again, my name is Michael Manning, and I am a reviewer in the
Division of Hematology, Oncology, Toxicology at the FDA, and I'm really pleased
to be the first person to begin this session.
So, to begin, animal testing has been considered
essential throughout the entire duration of modern anticancer drug
development. And the purpose of animal testing is primarily to assess safety
in ways that safety cannot be assessed in humans or have not yet been assessed in
humans. However, over the last 20 years
or so, there has been a trend in reducing animal use in drug
development. And there are many reasons for this.
I won't be comprehensive here, but a few of them would be the ethical concerns with
animal use,
the low predictability of animal studies, and this is particularly true for
certain types of products that are highly specific.
And also, just the development of more relevant and predictive
testing alternatives. And on this slide, I have listed some policy
initiatives that have sought to increase the use of alternative
methods and to limit animal testing.
And these policy initiatives represent an evolution of earlier
efforts,
expanding both their scope and impact.
Now, the most recent is the FDA's Roadmap to Reducing Animal
Testing in Preclinical Safety Studies, which was released
just last year in 2025. Now, the aim of the roadmap is
to replace routine animal testing with modern alternatives
within three to five years,
making animal studies the exception rather than the norm.
Now, a summary of all the ways FDA has promoted streamlined
non-clinical development programs can be found at the link on this
slide.
While reducing animal use and increasing the use of alternative methods
is a priority for all areas of drug development, the oncology
community was poised to become a leader in reducing animal testing,
and this is because of the unique considerations of oncology drug development.
First, there has been a drive to streamline non-clinical development programs
to avoid delays in developing anticancer drugs, and this, in
effect, has reduced some types of animal studies.
Second, patients with advanced cancer have different risk-benefit
considerations compared to the general population, and with that comes the
acceptance that fewer animal studies may be needed to assess
risk.
Third, patients with advanced cancer are closely monitored during
clinical studies.
These considerations have long been known, and guidances have been created to
provide for a more flexible and tailored approach to non-clinical safety
studies for anticancer drugs. These include the ICH S9
and ICH S9 Questions and Answers guidance.
These guidances specifically sought to avoid the unnecessary use of animals
in accordance with the replacement, reduction, and refinement
principles of animal use.
Importantly, there is no evidence that the reduction in animal testing
has compromised patient safety.
In fact, there is even a scientific basis for these alternative testing methods,
which may be more predictive and scientifically superior to animal
testing in certain circumstances.
One such way that the oncology community has championed the reduction in
animal testing has been with the acceptance and the promotion of weight-of-evidence
risk assessments.
Weight-of-evidence risk assessments are comprehensive approaches to evaluating
safety by combining multiple types of information rather than
relying on a single study or a single test method.
Weight-of-evidence risk assessments may include non-clinical and clinical
data generated with the investigational product,
literature-based assessments of potential toxicities based on the roles of the
molecular target in normal physiological processes and disease
settings, and may include new approach methodologies or
NAMs.
Weight-of-evidence risk assessments have been described in international and FDA
guidances.
These guidances describe when weight-of-evidence risk assessments can be
applied and provide general principles for what types of data to
integrate. I'll provide some examples on the next slide.
Weight-of-evidence risk assessments have proven useful in assessments of
reproductive toxicity, and weight-of-evidence risk assessments now commonly
replace
animal embryo-fetal developmental toxicology studies.
Weight-of-evidence risk assessments have also replaced three-month general tox
studies for select types of well-understood products, such as
CD3 bispecific T-cell engagers.
The use of weight-of-evidence risk assessments have been described in international
and FDA guidances.
On this slide, I've excerpted sections of three guidance documents to
show how weight-of-evidence risk assessments can be applied in non-clinical
drug development.First, the ICH S9
questions and answers guidance describes circumstances in which a weight of
evidence assessment of reproductive risk could be provided in
lieu of embryo-fetal developmental tox studies in pregnant
non-human primates.
Second, the FDA reproductive toxicity testing guidance
outlines circumstances in which a weight of evidence risk assessment
may eliminate the need to conduct dedicated embryo-fetal
developmental tox studies and describes the general
principles for what types of data to include in the weight of evidence risk
assessment.
Third, the FDA oncology therapeutic radiopharmaceuticals
guidance recommends an integrated risk summary to assess late
radiation toxicities in patients with long life expectancies.
These examples are just a few ways that weight of evidence risk assessments can be
applied in non-clinical drug development.
In addition to our work in regulatory review, our division at the FDA has been a
leader in regulatory research, results of which have advanced
the replacement, reduction, and refinement of animal use in
oncology drug development.
This regulatory research has been in key areas including CD3
bispecific T-cell engagers, antibody drug conjugates,
immuno-oncology products, and pediatric cancer drugs.
Results of this research have been published and shared in public venues.
Over the next two slides, I will highlight the impact of our research on the
non-clinical development of CD3 bispecific T-cell engagers and
antibody drug conjugates. For
this project, our research sought to find opportunities to streamline the
non-clinical development of CD3 bispecific T-cell engagers.
In this project, we analyzed data from INDs and BLA
submissions for CD3 bispecific T-cell engagers and determined
how often animal tox studies were not being conducted.
For example, due to lack of target binding in animals.
Oftentimes, longer duration tox studies were not feasible due to
immunogenicity and loss of drug exposure.
In these cases, other available safety data and literature were found to be
sufficient to inform chronic toxicity.
Our research concluded three-month general tox studies were
not warranted, and instead, weight of evidence risk assessments could assess the
chronic effects.
If there were a specific concern, it could be addressed through alternative methods
such as NAMs or clinical monitoring.
Our research in antibody drug conjugates sought to answer two key questions.
First, are animal data predictive of toxicities in patients?
And second, is a three-month tox study in non-human primates
warranted?
For this project, we analyzed data from IND and BLA submissions
for antibody drug conjugates with cytotoxic small molecule payloads.
We found the toxicities were due to the small molecule payloads, not the
antibody portion of the molecule.
We also found the longer-term tox studies were no more informative
than the shorter-term tox studies.
Our research concluded three-month general tox studies in non-human
primates are not warranted, and if a three-month study was
warranted, the study could be conducted in rodents only.
In summary, this is a rapidly advancing area, and the policy
initiatives will continue to accelerate the progress in reducing animal
testing and promoting the use of alternative methods.
This is most evident in the FDA's roadmap to reducing animal testing,
which again aims to make animal studies the exception rather than the
norm within three to five years.
Second, the oncology community has been a leader in reducing animal testing,
and this is not by chance. This is because of the unique considerations
of oncology drug development, as well as the results of years of
efforts to develop and promote the use of alternative methods.
Other areas of drug development are looking to the oncology community to
learn more about how to move forward with reducing animal testing and promoting the
use of alternative methods. Weight of evidence risk assessments.
These are powerful tools to reduce certain types of animal
studies. These are comprehensive approaches and are no less
informative than traditional animal studies.
And notably, this is an area again where the oncology community has been a
leader.
And lastly, our regulatory research is science-based.
It draws from primary data and has contributed to oncology drug development
being the leader in the reduction in animal testing and promoting the use
of alternative methods.
That is the end of my slides. I do want to acknowledge and thank the AACR
for allowing us to do this session, the collaborative work between the other
session panelists and the speakers, and lastly, the staff
management within my division at the FDA for their feedback in preparing this
session.
Thank you.
Thank you, Michael. And moving on to the next
presentation, Natalie Simpson.
Hello, my name is Natalie Simpson, and I am a lead toxicologist
in the Division of Hematology, Oncology, and Toxicology, and the title of my
talk is Incorporating New Approach Methodologies, or NAMs, in Oncology Drug
Development. And I also just wanted to add a note as well that
some of this work on the hiPSC ECMs
was conducted as part of the Immediate Office in
OND, so there's a broad representation there.
Can you also mention what those acronyms are?
The acronyms. OND is the Office
of New Drugs. Immediate Office is the central office that represents all
indications for pharm tox. It's not just oncology.
So...
I'm not sure how to advance this.
Use the keys. Keys.
The key? Oh.
There we go. Sorry. Okay. I first wanted to provide context that when defining
NAMs, there was no harmonized global definition.
The recent FDA roadmap discusses that NAMs can be 3D cell cultures,
organoids, organ-on-chip, in silico, including AI and computational
tox, and in chemical or omics, for example, protein assays.
A recent publication that came out from FDA by Yao et al, representing all
indications highlights where NAMs have replaced animal studies, suggesting that a
NAM can be anything that results in not conducting an animal toxicology
study. And then the Inter-Agency Coordinating Committee on the Validation of
Alternative Methods, also known as ICCVAM, released a report in
2024 that included 2D models in the definition of a NAM, and then the most
recent draft, CDER NAM's guidance that came out in March 2026,
also includes 2D models as NAMs.
But for the purposes of this talk, NAMs are going to be defined as human induced
pluripotent stem cell, or
hiPSC, derived 2D in vitro models.
For example, like hiPSC-derived cardiomyocytes, simple
3D in vitro models like organoid or spheroid, reproductive
toxicology alternative models like embryonic stem cell test, mouse or
hiPSC-derived, zebrafish embryo assay,
or complex in vitro models, which can be abbreviated as
CIVMs, which includes organs-on-chips.
And for the purposes of this talk, NAMs are not 2D models because as
we included simple 2D models in this definition, that would
include now effector function assays, cytokine release assays, and different
modeling approaches to support dose selection when there is lack of a
pharmacologically relevant species.
We have been using these models for years, and they
are present in most submissions, and we will continue to review them as we have in
the past.
On this slide, I'm providing a landscape analysis of human induced pluripotent stem
cell-derived cardiomyocytes, also known as hiPSC-CMs.
Searches at FDA have been conducted to identify submitted hiPSC-CM
studies to the Office of New Drugs,OND, and CDER,
Center of Drug Evaluation and Research, by searching for these studies using
keywords in the document title that were coined initially by Yang
et al in 2022. Those search terms or
keywords are cardiomyocyte, stem cell, or hiPSC-CM.
Results were originally published by Yang et al, and then later by myself and
colleagues in 2025, showing that nearly 100
studies were submitted as part of investigational new drug
applications, or INDs, to FDA from 2012 through 2023.
And then I recently updated the search in 2024 and
2025 and identified an additional 40 studies for a total of
139 hiPSC-CM studies submitted across divisions.
This still represents, though, only 1% of commercial IND
submissions per year, so there aren't that many.
DHAD has the highest percentage of these studies,
as you can see in the pie chart to the right, with a total of 61
studies submitted between 2012 and 2025 identified,
predominantly submitted to the safety pharmacology module
and measuring validated endpoints for
QT prolongation risk.
On this slide, like the hiPSC-CM landscape analysis, I am showing here that
organoid spheroid studies were also identified across divisions
by using organoid or spheroid keywords and searching the document
title for the study report. But this search was also expanded to completely
search the study report text to identify these
studies. And then there had to be a second evaluation because the keywords
are not that specific, so they pulled a lot of other studies that were not NAMs.
On the left side, that line graph, the number of
organoids per year submitted is shown in gray, and the number of spheroid
models is shown in black. So you can see that most of the studies have been
submitted in the past five years. When grouping the organoids and
spheroids together, most are submitted to oncology, as shown in the right pie
graph, with a total of 301 studies submitted between 2008 and
2025. The studies are mostly pharmacology studies,
proof of concept, for example,
and it makes sense since many cell lines grown under the right conditions form
spheroids.
This slide focuses specifically now on organoid spheroid studies submitted to
oncology through March of 2026. The left pie chart shows that
91% of organoid studies and the right chart shows that
86% of spheroid studies submitted to oncology are
submitted under pharmacology. Only 6% and 9% of
organoids and spheroids respectively submitted to oncology are safety NAMs,
meaning that they are submitted as other toxicology studies and
assess cytotoxic endpoints. The tissue types most represented by
organoids are gastrointestinal or GI, and most
spheroid studies are liver. As a side note, while most simple
NAMs are submitted to oncology,
when looking specifically at 3D liver spheroid models, more are submitted to
non-oncology divisions, as noted by the asterisks.
Second to liver spheroids were studies submitted assessing toxicity to multiple
tissue types as part of a T-cell directed
off-target activity assessments for biologics.
And another observation I want to point out is that one ReproTox study was
retrieved using the spheroid search term
in the table to the right, but we knew there were more.
So
using other keywords like stem cell or zebrafish identified another
25 studies submitted to oncology across 11 INDs,
highlighting the importance of
keywords in identifying these studies when they're submitted to FDA.
And one final point from this slide is that even though most simple 3D in vitro
NAMs are submitted to pharmacology, safety NAMs can have significant impact
on reducing animals as part of a weight of evidence with endpoint and
organ-specific considerations.
For example, hiPSC-CMs are a surrogate for QT assessment and
can replace that endpoint in certain cases and potentially more broadly.
NAMs can address also known class-specific toxicities as
well based on particular organs or tissues of
interest.When it comes to complex NAMs or
CIVMs, very few INDs in oncology have these.
When broadly searching the body of text of submissions using keywords like
complex in vitro model, CIVM, organ-on-chip,
organ chip, microphysiological system, or new approach method,
there are limited study reports with complex NAMs, and most are
discussed as part of meeting packages.
Only eight INDs discussing complex NAMs were identified, and four of these
proposed the NAMs as part of a weight of evidence to replace animal studies.
In building on the reprotox discussion from the previous slide, it has only
been even more recent. You can see the reprotox studies have been coming in for a
while, but only since 2024 that they've been
proposing reprotox NAMs in oncology to
replace the need for embryo-fetal development studies as part of a weight of
evidence. And as shown in the
chart below, the number of INDs with reprotox and complex
NAMs is increasing in DHOT, and we are actively keeping track of these
NAMs and submissions.
So circling back to using organ and endpoint-specific safety NAMs in risk
assessment, we do have a case study where a NAM supported animal
replacement. It was a bispecific.
The X arm contained variable regions from an approved drug with
toxicities for the target, and the toxicities for the target were well understood.
For the Y arm, several drugs are approved for the target, and toxicities were
also well understood. There's clinical experience with drugs
targeting each as a single agent in combination or as part of bispecifics,
and the sponsor proposed to use organ-on-chips for three different
tissue types to address toxicities expected based on experience with the
targets. No animal studies
were proposed for the first-in-human study, and the organ-on-chips were selected
based on known toxicities.
DHOT concluded that the NAMs could be used as part of a weight of
evidence approach in lieu of animal studies to support safety and starting
dose selection. For the weight of evidence, we noted it should include
primary pharmacology studies with appropriate positive control arms,
and the same controls should also be used for the safety NAMs that the sponsor
proposed.
And also that they include any additional information to what was proposed
originally to support the safety of the study
in lieu of the animal studies. And we encouraged the sponsor to follow up on the
need for additional non-clinical tests as development continues.
So in summary, most NAMs have been submitted to oncology.
3D models submitted are mainly for pharmacology proof of concept.
There has been an increase in safety NAMs in the past year and proposals to
reduce animal use, but still they're small percentages of submissions.
Currently, when to use NAMs is as part of a weight of evidence to better understand
and characterize toxicities when signals were identified and targeted safety
assessment, for example, products in the same class.
And lastly, in parting, we're open to reviewing NAMs.
They may enhance safety assessment while reducing and replacing certain animal
testing. If using NAMs, consult us early.
The timing is important, whether it's for first-in-human,
pre-IND, or later in product development for embryo fetal development studies.
And generally, there's more flexibility when included
as part of a weight of evidence. And I just want to thank everyone who helped
contribute to this talk, and I know I'm at time.
Thank you, Natalie. So hopefully, we convinced you that we are
flexible in our division so far. And the next talk is
Matt Thompson, A Glimpse into the Future in Bioinformatics.
Thank
you, Holly.
So I'm
happy to be here today. Matthew Thompson,
PharmTox supervisor, and I lead the DHOT
bioinformatics group.
And shaped by accumulating data and experience with class toxicities,
DHOT invites a discussion today.
To frame that discussion, I will present two hypothetical
study designs during the talk.
So at a time where there is an emphasis on reducing animal use,
it is worth stating that our mission to help get the
safest, most effective
oncology therapeutics to patients remains unchanged.
What has changed over time is the approach.
So when I started in 2015 at the agency,
the first IND submission I received came in
17 bankers boxes
into my office. It took up a quarter of the office.
We had paper jackets that were about this thick, and
you had to dig through one box for histopath and another box for
toxicokinetics, and another box for module three, and another box for the
clinical protocol. So you can imagine that that's not very
conducive to efficiency.
Now it's all electronic.
So ease of access to data and data that is more structured
changes how we think, how we analyze, how we conduct
internal research, and propose safer ways to develop drugs.
Another example of change is the approach to start dose
selection.
Some of the most highly consequential papers for setting
starting doses came out of DHOT in 2015, '16, and '17 on
ADCs and immuno-oncology products.
And as evidenced by how many times those papers are
cited under starting dose rationale and clinical protocols,
it's evident that the approach continues to evolve beyond STD10s
and H&STDs for selecting starting doses for certain product
types, and we should expect this.
The more experience we get with a class,
the more we can fine-tune
approachesSo I
mentioned the move from paper to electronic
documents. So what was the next move?
For us, a little over three years ago,
we initiated the creation of a database of now over
8,000 commercial INDs in oncology,
cataloging the mechanisms, targets, and classes by
product.
So it became so much easier, especially the clinical teams, to
ask questions like, what other INDs have the same target?
Is this first in class?
Has that starting dose approach led to a safe dose in patients?
The database and the dashboard that reviewers use
to quickly access this information,
made everything more efficient.
The time spent searching could now be spent analyzing, and that
creates a number of new opportunities, whether it be
cataloging and searching for NAM submissions or developing
quantitative models, or at least understanding the quantitative models
submitted in INDs to support starting dose.
So 11 years ago, it was 17 boxes of paper
in my office and no efficient way to find related products and
understand class toxicities.
And today, we have digital information, target databases, and
a rapid development of reviewer tools to study class
toxicities internally in-house.
And this is critical
because there is a rapid increase in oncology commercial IND
submissions. You can see the curves, especially since 2010.
It's an increase in both biologics and small molecule submissions.
And this represents the target database we've developed.
This represents that data pull.
This overall trend provides a look at how active oncology drug development
has become, and it points to a great opportunity to collect
data and improve regulatory decision-making and advice.
And this can change how resources are allocated,
including with respect to reducing animal use.
So briefly for context, this is a simple diagram
depicting the main time points for submission of animal data for a typical
non-clinical program to support an oncology indication under
S9.
So a major allocation of resources in terms of animal use is for GLP
repeat dose toxicology studies
to support first-in-human starting dose.
Usually, four weeks in duration is the first vertical line, and
a three-month repeat dose toxicology study to support a registrational
trial.
Considering both the increase in oncology IND submissions I
showed and that first-in-human submissions
have been historically supported by the conduct of GLP animal
toxicology studies, we can anticipate an increase in animal use,
which begs the question, which species are being used to support
regulatory submissions? So this pie chart shows the proportion of
GLP repeat dose toxicology studies by species submitted to the
agency since 2017.
So note the three biggest wedges are for rat, monkey, and dog,
with the non-rodent monkey and dog species making up the biggest
proportion.
So in light of the division's research
on starting dose approaches and class toxicity, it seems reasonable
to ask whether
the data support alternate approaches and designs
that can generate adequate safety information while also reducing
animal use.
So this leads us to the two main slides of the talk.
So based on accumulating data,
is there an opportunity to reduce animal studies that may
not be warranted and instead take a weight of evidence approach?
So this figure depicts a hypothetical stepwise approach to the
conduct of a three-month study in non-rodents.
It considers small molecules apart from biologics, small molecules being on
top, biologics being in the middle.
The bottom panel shows a hypothetical clinical development timeline.
Note the initiation lines, the vertical lines for initiation of a first-in-human
clinical study and later-phase clinical studies.
And above the clinical diagram is the corresponding non-clinical study timeline,
with one-month studies preceding the first-in-human clinical
development study.
And the questions we pose are the following.
Assuming species are pharmacologically relevant,
for a small molecule drug with one-month studies having been
conducted in rodent and non-rodent,
could a three-month rodent study
and a weight of evidence assessment in lieu of a non-rodent three-month
study
be sufficient to support safety?
And this is considering in the scope of from when an IND
is first submitted all the way through marketing.
For a biologic with a one-month study having been conducted in a
pharmacologically relevant non-rodent, could a weight of evidence assessment
in lieu of a non-rodent three-month study be sufficient to support safety?
So a stepwise approach could consider results from the one-month studies,
other non-GLP or PK studies, knowledge of target and
pathway,
additional non-animal tests, NAMs, and non-clinical and
clinical experience with the class.
So we would ask you, what
do you anticipate are the challenges and opportunities?
The second hypothetical design is focused on
streamlining development.Could one-month and three-month
studies in non-rodents be combined into a single study?
With this design for non-rodents, the first month of the study could
provide in live data to support initiation of a clinical study.
Note, the typical timing of the rodent studies has not changed.
What are the anticipated challenges, we would ask, to what types of products could
this be applied? Biologics, small molecules, certain classes.
So DHOT continues to focus on supporting the development of safe and
effective oncology therapeutics,
including by developing informatics resources, like I've mentioned, and tools to
inform our thinking
on toxicology study designs.
We have an ongoing retrospective analysis considering mechanism of action, target
and class, comparing three and one-month repeat dose toxicology
results, safety signals, comparing those to clinical study
results,
the value of histopathology in these assessments,
and whether alternative approaches can adequately assess safety and
inform gaps in our knowledge.
DHOT invites a discussion on the hypothetical toxicology study designs
discussed or ideas for streamlining non-clinical
development.
So I want to thank the audience
for attending and AACR for hosting this symposium. I also want to thank Dr.
Saber and Ricks and the OCE for their support of the
informatics unit in DHOT. And I also want to make sure I thank
Doctors
Joelle Gils and Ian MacWilliams, who are major contributors to the
informatics team right now.
Finally, the division is looking to hire pharmacology
toxicology reviewers
with bioinformatics and quantitative modeling experience.
It's not a typical profile for a pharm tox reviewer, so we really need
more expertise. I'll be available to those who are interested during the AACR
meeting if you'd like to discuss.
Thank
you, Matt. Now, I would like to ask
all panelists
to reflect and react to the presentations.
And after that, I will be asking the audience to please ask your
questions.
Please, starting with Rod at the very end.
You went in the wrong order.
No, I think, again, this sets up the stage for hopefully
a robust discussion. And,
I'd also like to reiterate, DHOT, in my experience, I've had a
lot of interactions with Ale and a lot of the pharm tox reviewers over time.
And I think the weight of evidence approach has been underutilized, and there's
opportunities to even expand that.
And I think it was highlighted, chronic toxicity studies, reprotoxicity
studies have been very successful with our experience in using weight of
evidence. And where I'd like, hopefully, it can come in the future is maybe
even supporting those, like you just saw that as an example, in that first in
human study, as we get more and more experience with these
multi-specific antibodies that use,
and I focus on antibodies, that use CDRs of two
known approved drugs. And the combination data is already out there.
You put them in one molecule, the likelihood of having unknown
toxicities or other things
happen is pretty unlikely. And I think that weight of evidence can be really strong
because it's going to be based on clinical data. It's not non-clinical data.
So I think those opportunities are going to be available even more so as we start
to combine approved products into one molecule.
The two species to weight of evidence and going to a one
species, I think that is another opportunity, and the only
comment I would have on that is selecting the one species that
has the most translatable safety.
Because then you could use the weight of evidence the other one.
So if that happens to be a large animal species, you go with that one.
But you still are reducing and refining, and you might be able to reduce the number
of animals because, again, you have that known translation.
So those are just some of the things that I've noted, and again, I think this is a
really good opportunity to have a discussion in terms of where we can start
leveraging that, as well as some of these NAM approaches to
supplement the weight of evidence, to supplement our typical and
gold standards.
Thank you, Rod. I'm also taking notes.
We'll discuss these when you go back to the FDA.
Shannon, please.
Great. Well, thank you again for the talks.
So one thing that I think really stood out to me is, we're seeing this increase
in NAMs at the same time that we're seeing a rapid shift in drug modalities.
So even at this conference, we've seen some of the newer cell
therapies, multi-specifics, engineered peptides,
and other really complex biologics.
And so these new therapies are engaging biology in
ways that maybe the traditional safety assessment paradigms
weren't really created to take that into account.
And so I think it's not just even a technical challenge
that we're facing, but really a conceptual challenge.
How do we really think about assessing safety in
this new era and for really thinking about the
dynamic human specific biology that we're seeing?
And NAMs, I think, are going to really offer a valuable opportunity to
align our models with the biology that we are really trying to understand.
Thank you, Shannon.
Jacinta?
Thank you. Yeah, I want to thank you again for
coming and having this session and showing
that DHOT and FDA are
paving the way for these alternatives approaches.
I think if we continue to do this and expand
beyond regional to,
we need to globally harmonize on these weight of evidence approaches and
streamlined approaches,
that we'll really move the needle.
So again, thank you to DHOP for doing that.
I'm just going to...
The other piece was just to continue to expand on
what Rod and Shannon were saying. So, as we think about
the weight of evidence approach, we've heard kind of two different
aspects. We've heard Rod saying that it's very amenable when you
have known targets, known biology,
known modalities. So that's where we've already been applying these
types of approaches. And you could argue that
it's more difficult when you have new
biology, new modalities. But if they are human specific,
we are going to have to innovate, right, to be able to answer those
questions. So,
we're at an interesting
hinge point,
where we're both trying to leverage existing knowledge, but also
being able to apply advances in
science and technology to these new modalities. So, thank you.
I'll pass it on to you, Tiffany.
So I agree that I think low-hanging fruit is
using weight of evidence assessments, and NAMs can
be incorporated into that as supportive information.
One example where that's been effective is with embryo-fetal development
studies where
weight of evidence is default for biologics.
And the FDA repro guidance also
encourages weight of evidence also for small molecules as well.
And so we've started to see sponsors
proposing weight of evidence assessments for small molecules, and we've accepted
those approaches.
I'm looking forward to the discussion on the hypothetical tox
design
that Matt just discussed.
What are the opportunities there? What are the challenges?
What types of drugs would this be appropriate for, which wouldn't be
appropriate? And then are there other non-clinical approaches that we
should be considering that you could talk to us about today?
Thank you.
So now I open it to all of you.
Please come to the mic, ask your questions.
Hi, my name is Winston Tang. I was a medical reviewer in CBER
from 2017 to 2021. I'm an
entrepreneur starting up biotech companies.
I was very excited when this came along.
As you probably know,
Mercedes Sarabian, who used to head up the CBER
tox, and she had advocated even back in 2017 to cutting down animal
studies. So I was very excited when the guidance came out.
And I've been exploring this for the last year because what I'm doing now, I'm an
entrepreneur starting up new companies.
So when this came out, I started calling CROs that do
these types of studies. And the two problems I face, number one,
there is no single provider that will give me a panel of
chips or organs that will cover
all the different organ systems in this thing.
So I would have to go to company A to do the liver, company
B to do the lung.
And even more important, none of these tests are validated,
which means that I'm going to have to do animal studies to prove that whatever
data I give you on these chips or cell cultures are
relevant to what's happening in vivo.
So, you know-
Excellent question
... as a startup company, my resources are limited.
So if I'm going to have to do an animal tox to prove to you that what I'm showing
here in the cell culture is relevant, I might as well just do the
animal tox and save time and money.
Excellent question. Thank you. So that will
bridge to the next question I have
for
our FDA folks.
Do we accept NAMs that are not validated, or the NAMs that
we've used so far, they were all validated?
And then I'm going to go to
Rod, Jacinta, and Shannon and get their feedback
on validation versus fit for purpose.
My thoughts
are that
if it
is as part of a weight of evidence and you have
justification that the animal...
In your case, it's going to be
animal relevant, pharmacological relevant. Is that your...
Or is it human relevant?
Human, yeah.
I have one target. When you do a
PubMed search,
10 papers published.
Then I have other targets that are more common.
So basically, it's fine. Some of them, the class effect,
let's say on ADC or T-cell engagers are well known.
Yes.
But, the off-target effects, there's going to be much less
information.
Yes.
Especially that one target in which there's only 10 papers published.
Yeah.
So,
when it comes to needing a
validated NAM, you're right, there are very
few.
Ways to incorporate that in
your program would be appropriate controls,
that if you have the appropriate positive and control.
If you're using
those controls and then you're comparing to something else, and we
understand that other
mechanism fairly well in the same class, for
example,
then we would be able to
make that comparison and it wouldn't necessarily need to be fully validated.
It could be the appropriate controls
where we can make the correct comparison.
But this would not be for full animal replacement.
It is still going to be part of a weight of
evidence.
But that's the question. What is the control? Is it an animal?
No, no.
No. It would be like... Yeah.
For the example that Natalie presented where
the sponsor proposed NAMs and we accepted NAMs,
it was part of a weight of evidence.
So in our weight of evidence, when there is sufficient other data,
such as
they had comparative pharmacology studies to show that they're
comparable to some other products in a class, and the
NAMs was selected based on known
toxicity. So it wasn't for all the
organs in a body. It was three selected NAMs
based on expected known toxicities.
So,
those are fit for purpose in our repro studies because
those are, again, weight of evidence. They've been fit for purpose.
Yeah, I agree. If we wait for validation,
validation would be needed at some point.
So we have to reduce animal studies, at the same time,
increase the use of NAMs and go towards
validation, because at some point in the future, animal
studies will be eliminated. I don't know how many years, but at some point.
At that point, we want validation when it comes to elimination.
So like for a new target, you're going to have to build for it.
But-
Yeah.
So, but right now, the model that we have is for
well-characterized targets. They are being used because we know
what the toxicities are, fit for purpose with appropriate positive
and negatives, and they've been accepted.
Yeah. And also too, a part of your weight of evidence, if you can
justify
the limitations of the animal model.
Maybe for example, the way your product works,
and
there's been examples, for example, with neutrophils.
Certain products,
based on the epitopes that are exposed
in cancer versus in animals that you're targeting, it'll have a
different tox profile based on this, humans versus the
monkey, for example. If there are certain binding,
if there is a big binding difference.
If there's things you can find that are limitations in the animal models,
to bring that to light, then that helps to give you a better
argument that this NAM is going to be
useful and building on that.
That's what the weight of evidence
can help is if you
build... If it's a completely relevant species, it's a
target that we've never seen before, a mechanism we don't really understand, it's
going to be very hard to say that NAMs
can replace that animal. But if it's a mechanism that you
well understand
or it belongs in a class with other products and there's
limitations to the species, that comprehensively could be used to
build a case potentially to reduce some studies and the
NAMs can fill that gap, should give more confidence
if you're doing comparisons within the NAM, that it
could support safety and inform a dose selection as well.
Because that's ultimately where if you're going to be doing less animals, that's
where we're going to
need to know how to set a starting dose.
So it's just thinking in that mindset of what all of your
tools, which is going to be the best to give you the answer,
and
going in the direction of trying to use the animal less and less as more of these
models do become validated. And even published studies, like
hIPSCs, ECMs are not formally
qualified yet in i 立 stand.
But there are tons of publications out there showing that they
are reliable models for QT
prolongation risk. With the
liver NAMs, they have a good panel where they have a good idea of how many
drugs. They have a good list of drugs that cause DILI, drugs that don't
cause DILI, that they've run in these models.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be validated through formal FDA means
too, for us to look at and build confidence in these studies.
And again, it all boils down to at what level are you-- How
relevant is the animal and to what level are you trying to
replace the animal entirely.
I want to give the opportunity. Thank you, Natalie.
I'm sorry.
I want to give the opportunity to other people to also answer.
Yeah. No. I'm rambling.
If I can quickly elaborate on one aspect is that, your questions is in the
context of NAMs, and we're discussing it in more of a, how
it could be incorporated into a weight of evidence.
And a weight of evidence is a comprehensive approach, not just NAMs.
We can also rely on existing animal data from previous studies,
or for studies
you conducted, or for which you have read a reference.
The weight of evidence could also rely on the mechanistic
information about the biologic pathways or the
disease settings, again, from the published literature.
The problem is the early phase studies are non-GLP.
That's not necessarily.
Yeah.
The early clinical studies that we conduct to look at the biology pharmacology
would not be GLP.
In this context, that wouldn't necessarily be an issue.
Yeah. A weight of evidence can use any animal studies, non-GLP, John,
GLP.
Yeah.
Any useful information. So if your non-GLP study
provides useful information, include it in your weight of evidence.
Yeah, weight of evidence approaches can be very comprehensive.
You can draw from many lines of evidence.
That's what makes these so useful and powerful.
Anybody else wants to...
Don't want to spill the water.
Yeah, I would just add, it depends on when you want to use and incorporate some of
these complex in vitro systems, because you could actually use it
early on screening. And again, I think the data was out there that a lot of this
is done in pharmacology. And so,
we're talking about safety, but in essence, we're also talking about reducing
animals in general, and a lot of the animals that we use are in pharmacology
models. If we can demonstrate pharmacology in some of these complex
systems that, again, are consistent, then we can
go and maybe limit what we need to do, because then we know what to
potentially look for in what target organs are there.
And so, that's where I think the supplemental part of it is.
If you can demonstrate that in these in vitro systems
with the appropriate
clinical data sets or whatever, then that just targets that target
organ. And so then you can still reduce animal usage more
globally than just in safety.
But there's another problem that's not really independent of the
regulatory burden. It's the fact that when you go to funding agency,
VCs and whatnot, they want to see the animal studies.
Again-
They want to see it in a cancer model that you are able to increase
survival relative to whatever control. So, you know...
Again, and I think this was brought up, we have to have a mind shift.
Not just us, not just regulatory authorities, not just
pharma, but VC people. And I was at small biotech
before as well, and I've seen this. I agree.
It's like, and we were talking about it earlier,
you have medicinal chemists tell you, "I don't care what those NAMS
say, I just want to see safety in rodents." And
we can't run
20 molecules through rodents to help them select.
That's just not feasible. So we have to rely on other things, and I think everybody
has to have that mind shift that we want to reduce animals.
And we have to understand a little bit about the biology and a little bit about the
chemistry to pick the appropriate ones.
Because there's a gap there, too, like you said.
We don't have NAMS for every organ system either.
So we have to understand what that is.
Yes. And I want to emphasize what Rod said, is
that we have not eliminated animal
toxicology studies. We have reduced, and we are reducing.
The thing is, there's a financial burden that has to be borne by
the biotech community until there's sufficient data.
Thank you. Going next person, you're next, and then
we'll go to Whitney.
Oh, actually. Yeah, great discussion. So I have a question.
So, right now, the FDA released a general consideration for
incorporating NAM in drug development.
And one thing we already kind of briefly touched base is about for those
assay tests, doesn't necessarily need to be validated.
But in that case, if, for example, liver model, there are so
many ways to create a liver model for toxicity.
And different people may use different kind of
technology, right? So, platform.
So, in that case, although even we have the positive control, negative control
included in the package,
how does FDA really evaluate the data submitted
from this package or from another package?
So, will you eventually come up with a guideline, kind of, oh, if
you want to delete assay for this particular drug
and the modality, or you have to use this model,
or is any timeline or just a consideration about that?
Well, right now we are open, and the sponsors
will put a package together and justify what
non-clinical plan they have and why.
Mm-hmm.
And in the future, I'm sure there will be
a guidance.
But right now, it's too early to make those recommendations.
Right now, we are open to suggestions,
and we have proposals that you saw,
and it's later in product development, where we
have animal data, like one-month studies.
We have human data as well. But surely at
some point in the future, I think we need a guidance.
But right now, build your case, present it to us,
what you want to do and why you want to do it that way.
Mm-hmm. But if I don't incorporate any animal data in the package,
just the in vitro NAM system data, will it get rejected?
Well, Matt, do you want to talk about your case?
It depends.
We really are caring a lot about target and mechanism.
Mm-hmm.
For certain classes, I'm using the word class kind of loosely-
Mm.
... it determines everything. I mean, I can think to, like, KIMMTRAK, which
is tobentafusp. It's a GP100 peptide, HLA-directed
C3 bispecific.
Mm.
That had no tox data. It had alloreactivity,
it had a platelet activation assay, and some cross-reactivity.
That was the tox package.
And it's been approved.
No animals.
So it was approved without animal data.
No animal data. Now, that's a case where there wasn't a pharmacologically relevant
species, but it shows you, if you set that aside, it shows you, you
can develop a drug
without necessarily doing animal studies. So...
Thank you.
Yeah, I think I would encourage people to submit
what they have for NAMS. We are not seeing enough submissions for NAMS.
And we know people are doing them.
Other panelists, do you want to comment?
Yeah, I was going to comment that-There was an example about liver,
for instance.
So early on, for small molecules,
we are using in vitro systems and in silico tools to
predict, is this molecule potentially going to cause drug-induced
liver injury? And then we're using those methods to
try to screen out what could be a bad actor.
So as Rod was saying, that will ultimately reduce the number of
molecules going through animal studies because we've
filtered them out earlier. But then we're not really using those
models to test the overall safety of your final
candidate
unless we identify in an animal study that there's a
liver toxicity, and now we're trying to understand if that liver toxicity may occur
in human.
So that would be part of your weight of
evidence. Maybe you're not doing another animal study to evaluate that.
You're now doing a more translatable human-based liver assay to see if
you would
see that finding. But of course, you'd have to look very carefully at the
particular
in vitro method to make sure that the right
cell types were there to really be able to recapitulate what might be
happening, which is still challenging.
So, I think,
as everybody's been pointing out, you really have to sit down and do a
thorough
thought process on what the potential
liabilities, the putative liabilities, might be based on the
modality, based on the target,
and
determine if you have a way to answer those questions without an in
vivo study.
Mm-hmm.
And only when you can answer them without an in vivo study would
I put it forward.
So that could even be for when you have a pharmacologically relevant
species. You can still go through that exercise.
Yes.
But if you don't have a pharmacologically relevant species at all, you still have
to demonstrate that you don't have a
pharmacologically relevant species, and then how are you going to answer these
safety questions? Or do you have a really
solid clinical monitoring and management plan, and
you're starting really low in the clinic and carefully
dosing up in the clinic. So there's multiple factors
that go into developing your overall
strategy.
Yeah. Thank you. I want to ask you, Shannon, because we are
talking about limitations of NAMs, about
multi-organ NAMs and the challenges.
Because years ago, there was some talks about connecting all the
organs to each other, and now I don't hear anything.
Yeah.
Can you comment on that?
I can definitely comment on that. First, I just wanted to also touch on
the point about multiple liver models and which one.
And what's really interesting now is there is this collaborative 3Rs where you
have nine different technology companies kind of collaborating together for
their liver models and work with pharma to understand
where they're fitting within the drug development and kind
of limitations and utilities. So I think that data
will be really interesting to come out and really see that head-to-head comparison
of the technology companies. In terms of multi-organ, yeah, I think
the field has kind of shifted. Initially, it was how do we make a
full human-on-a-chip? I think now there's still
excitement around multi-organ, but more targeted fit for
purpose and things like being able to really look
at exposure
and recapitulate exposure in a more human relevant way by
connecting an intestine, a liver, and a kidney.
So now you have the opportunity to assess metabolism or
absorption metabolism, and then downstream toxicity and really
metabolite-derived effects as well.
And so, I think that's going to be really exciting to see it.
Now, there's still challenges. As you have these complexities and you try to
scale,
it's more difficult to maintain and really to get to that
throughput. But I think the technology's evolving so
quickly, and that type of data feeding into AI models will really be powerful
too to accelerate and scale the work.
Thank you.
Going to Whitney.
Yeah. Okay. I'll take the chem track to start with.
That one,
you had no choice.
There's no animal data that you could support. I remember being very scared.
And also,
the dose was extremely low. So if you start going into
these non-animal models, which we're not defining as 2D here, but
the T cell engagers, they really are kind of
non-animal. Well, you're calling them novel approach, but a non-animal
model just sets everything up. And you have your paper about the
start doses being super low. So if you go into these other kind
of modalities and you're
using these NAMs, and you're using the DILI
models and the liver screening. Which yes, we can do all of that early
and try to cut out compounds that we don't want to take forward, and I think people
are using them there, but you're not getting them at FDA for that purpose
because those aren't the molecules that you're really looking at.
But how are you going to balance that start dose
kind of approach and being stuck in this sort of PAD
space, maybe not a true Mable, but more of a PAD space
versus
an HNSTD or a one-sixth the-
Yeah. Right.
Because those are much higher doses, which you've argued very
eloquently in your ADC papers. And
the T cell engagers are still down in these microgram levels.
Definitely, we need to improve.
And it's-
Yes
... hard to figure out what to base it on.
But it's
not just pharm tox. We need to also rethink clinical
trial designs. So the way we managed with
CD3 bispecifics or some other IO products, when
the first in-human dose is low, we worked with our
clinicians for intra-patient dose escalation to make sure patients
are quickly going up to receive the therapeutic dose.
So we need to work together and collaborate, and
yes, it's not perfect right now. It's
right at the beginning, where
2025, this
FDA news was out, and there's been a lot of efforts in
improving and working on all the limitations and everything. Please.
Yeah, I was going to add, when TCEs came up again, I think everybody was a
little scared
at first. But as we got more and more
information, more and more clinical data, I would say that now the
FDA listens and hears and thinks about that, not
just, "You're going to go to MABEL." If you have a justification,
and again, it can be partly because you have other clinical data, you're a
second-generation molecule where you've de-risked certain things, you can then go
in and say, "Because of this, we should be able to start at this dose."
And again, we've been successful at starting at well
above MABEL,
classical defined Mabels, by using that.
And again, so when we try and
characterize and do some of these in vitro models, if there's a soluble receptor,
we actually put that in the CRS assay, because that can change your starting
dose by 100-fold. Yet, that's what
oncology patients may have. And so we said, "That's more pharmacologically
relevant." And again, we've had no pushback on that.
So I think now people are getting more and more comfortable looking at that
data saying, "We don't want to go down to MABEL," and this is still
reasonable, yet still maintaining patient safety.
And then again, incorporating the clinical escalation, trying to
go as quickly as possible up to that pharmacologically relevant dose.
And the PK models are using the PK-
Yeah
... and parameters from related products as well.
Yeah, we're getting a lot of trimer models now and accepting them.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Question?
Sure. So
definitely can see a niche where it makes a lot of sense where you can potentially
skip animals if there's a lot known about that space,
about how this class works. So that absolutely makes
sense where there might be situations where you pick a couple relevant
ones. I guess on the other end,
part of the reason of doing animal work is for the
unpredicted toxicities of you know where you expect this to be
active, but you don't know what you don't know, so you have to put it in a whole
animal and kind of see if there's something that we weren't expecting.
So there has to be a tipping point
where the weight of evidence suggests we
probably do understand all of the risks
versus
we're not comfortable with that extent of risk.
I'm just curious where
folks think that balance point might be.
And if, it might be too early to ask this question, but for
things that have gone into the clinic
with just NAMs,
have there been a difference in unexpected
toxicities in any of those, or has it been equivalent
to the historical precedent?
Who wants to answer that question?
I'll do the first part, and you can do the second part.
Okay.
No, the first part, you're right. I think there are certain
technologies and certain platforms that are more amenable to NAM
approaches, and biologics being part of that.
Because biologics typically don't have the promiscuity that small molecules do.
And the small molecules, it's typically the off-target.
And that's where even I, with NAMs, it's like you said.
You don't know what you don't know.
And so how many NAMs would you actually have to do for a small
molecule to really understand that versus going into an animal
species? But I think what we're also saying is maybe you can do a short-term
study and understand that, and then you can start supplementing these later-term
studies with NAM approaches to obviate the need of having three
dose levels or two species or something.
So overall, we will eventually reduce that.
And I think that's why for the NAM-only approaches, Jacintha and other
people have already mentioned it, where there's no pharmacologically relevant
species, that's well accepted. It's pretty
straightforward. Where there is a relevant species, you can
still even sometimes
use your weight of evidence approaches to say, "We understand this" or "We
understand the target" or "We understand the mechanism of action sufficiently that
it doesn't matter, and we aren't going to learn anything more.
We aren't going to learn that much more information." I'll get to the...
So you can answer the second part in terms of which ones.
See if we can project again the slide that Matt presented
where the weight of evidence was in the three months.
Can
we do that?
At seven.
There's probably two other classes, ASO
and AAV. There
is so much data generated for those are all class one.
Yes.
Those are amenable to a weight of evidence approach, right?
We
mentioned here in one of the presentations that for antibody
drug conjugates,
there's
data supporting not conducting a large animal three-month
toxicity study because the toxicity is due to the payload,
right? The linker payload,
and that can be seen in a rodent.
Usually, you're using a non-human primate because it's pharmacologically relevant
for the antibody portion, right?
But there's also publications
from last year as well where this is if you are using the
same platform, so the same linker payload you could apply this
thinking even earlier, right? Do you even need
a large animal study at all to support
your first in-human filing right?
A rodent study to look at the... Or you could
even ask yourself if you need the rodent study.
If you're using a linker payload that you've used multiple times
before, right? You already have that data in hand, that's part of your weight of
evidence. So the same principles could be applied to
other modalities once you start building up those data sets.
And thank you. And looking at this slide again, Matt's
slide, so the weight of evidence is on the right side.
I'm losing it. See, this is the weight of evidence.
So the one-month studies would pick up off-target effect.
Then this is an overly simplified
phase one trial.
Actually, they would be in a three plus three design, about
36 to 40 patients are usually exposed.
It's a hypothetical, so let's say 30 patients exposed.
So those you'll have off-target effects and safety data from
there. Then you have mechanism of action.
Has anything progressed through that yet?
Yes. So this is later
when there is a lot of data, and then it's paired
with a three-month rodent.
So additional off-target effects will be picked up here, let's
say.
What I'm asking is, are there any compounds that have gone through this process
all?
Oh, this is a pilot. We're asking.
Okay.
We're asking, do you have any concern?
Do you want this to be improved? And if you want this to be improved,
in what way? Will you limit it to certain class of products?
Or it's saying, start with your weight of evidence.
Can we start with a weight of evidence?
And if the answer is, "I don't have enough data," then
say, "Okay, maybe I need an animal study," rather
than saying, "I need an animal study," right at the get go.
Change the question, change the order.
Okay. Yeah. And then eventually there will be more yeses to, "I don't need an
animal study." That makes sense.
We hope so. We're thinking this could be the next step,
the next pilot, and we'll see if it works.
We wanted to present to see if you have any comments, concern, questions.
This is one of the pilots.
I think to address, to speak to some of the previous questions,
something that would be very helpful to the industry, specifically to CROs,
like the example of multiple different ways to model liver.
If we could get guidance from FDA on what is acceptable
to kind of set a benchmark for various groups or tissue types
or areas of concern, that would align
various CROs on what they should be using or developing,
and that would give a clearer path so we don't necessarily have several different
groups spending lots of resources
doing the same thing in different ways.
And NAM is not mandatory as part of the weight of evidence.
You can have a NAM because you saw some signal of
toxicity, or you can have just enough information without a
NAM-
Okay
... as part of a weight of evidence.
Weight of evidence means you have all this data from early
on, you have all this data from in humans.
You have publications that indicate there's such and such
toxicities. There are other products in class that say
these are the toxicities. If this is an oligo, you probably
know a lot about toxicities.
So maybe even we can move to this part and say weight of
evidence for some of these. But anyway, the question is just three-month studies.
Okay.
Yeah, I think as more happen, we'll-
Yes
... be more comfortable with doing it.
Yes, at some point in the future to have-
I was going to bring up an a really long historical, or not long,
but long time ago. Again, I was at a
company working with Sieber, and we had a
Listeria-based platform for a cancer vaccine.
We did a couple of non-human primate studies, and by the time we got to the
third of our platform, they were like, "You don't need to do
another tox study because your platform is what is the toxicity.
It's not the antigen you're putting in the platform." So all we had to do was a
biodistribution study in a mouse.
And so this was 20 years ago, over 20 years ago that we were doing this.
So, I think as, again, as health authorities see these
platform effects,
they are getting more and more comfortable saying, "Yes, that's a platform effect,
and you don't need to do your Cadillac version of every study.
You can really streamline this and go very quickly and do what's
needed." But don't, as Hele just pointed out, don't
just go in and say, "We need to do a tox study in two species every
single time." I think we can start to have that discussion now.
I think Mike wanted to say something.
But you are, yeah, you are submitting that data as supportive.
I just want to briefly just make sure we're all on the same page with what the
definition of a pilot is. And correct me if I'm wrong, but a pilot,
we are currently amenable to reviewing this right here, like today,
right?
Yeah. This is a pilot.
This is a pilot.
Pilot.
So this isn't necessarily something that could be years in the future.
This is
possible, feasible today. This could be a submission
that could be reviewed.
Okay.
A pilot. It means we'll
entertain it, see if it works,
then decide whether it's here to stay.
Go ahead, Natalie.
Hi.
All right.
I just have a
couple comments to some of your questions.
The draft guidance is broad right now, that's been put
out, but there are plans
from what I've heard, and Hele may be able to comment too more on this, because
to have more specific ones as you're describing, it's just not yet
for models.
That's fair.
There are plans, but they just now have put
a very broad... validation
guidance out for CEDR. I'm not sure if you're aware of
that. I'd referenced it on my slide, but it's very
general, not specific particular model, but describes
certain aspects that you'd be looking for
in technical characterization.
Not validation. You're referring to the March-
Yeah, the validation-
... March, yeah
... part of what you're talking about with the
wanting guidance on how to do, for example, all the different liver models and
stuff like that. It's broad. It's not specific.
But
my understanding is there are plans to eventually, through
work that's been going on with the-
Yes, correct
... multiple
liver platforms, things that will come into eventually having more of a
guidances tailored when we understand a model well, so to give more
guidance there.
Yeah. There was a March guidance
was out on now.
Yeah. It's a draft one, a draft guidance. I don't know if you want to...
And then the other thing I just wanted to quickly mention is
that,
from what I heard, a lot of what you're saying is that there's uncertainty that you
may be missing something, and so you run the animal study to build
confidence. And a lot of,
I think,
it's just to continue to circle back and see,
you're afraid you're missing something, but are you?
Yeah.
Everybody has got to be doing it. We do retrospective studies.
There's a lot of retrospective analysis.
But it all honestly has to be prospective.
You need to be continually, and
everybody, again, a mindset shift.
Is doing this non-rodent
adding anything to the rodent? Could we use
QSAR? Could we use
NAMs? Are there things that we could
do where we wouldn't have to do the non-rodent study?
And that is going to come from big data, continually need to collect
the data, circling back from once you get the clinical findings
to kind of know
that whether or not you really needed it.
I think it's just going to, and the more we're doing this, more
industry is looking back, more FDA is looking back, getting
confidence that maybe these extra
studies that were run didn't add anything, then you're going to have more
confidence that you're not missing something.
Sure.
And the NAMs are a part of that, but a little bit of it is
understanding
if
we really are missing things by doing these extra studies.
So I hope that addresses some of your concerns.
Yes. Imagine if this is another, like a me too, like a
product in the same class. Do we really need another dogs or monkeys
study when we have so much information out there?
I want to go to the next person.
I had a big picture question. So Natalie, on one of your
slides, you mentioned that there is no global harmonization
with respect to the definition of NAMs.
So are there the greater conversations between agencies
with respect to what that definition is,
when we could expect that, so that potentially the databases
are comparable or
larger?
Well, I think Jacinta can answer this question.
Yeah, that's what I was going to think, so you just-
It's fine.
Yeah, I can comment. So,
when I introduced myself, I said that I'm contributing through
pharma, a cross-industry organization,
to writing or drafting a ICH reflection
paper on NAMs, because what a reflection paper does
is it outlines areas where we need global harmonization,
and it can be a driver for
editing, I guess, or modifying an existing
guidance or for a new guidance. So in
that
pharma-led
initiative, we do get the opportunity to speak with various parties of
ICH, right? Where FDA is one. And we've started to talk
about what
is the definition of NAM. Now, I don't think we're going to get to that
in the reflection paper, but it will be put in there
as
a topic, right, for harmonization so that there can be one aligned
view on what a NAM actually is. And, you've heard here today,
we talk about weight of evidence,
and some health authorities feel that a weight of evidence
is a NAM, right? And others think that
a NAM is part of a weight of evidence.
So we've had to step back from there because we're all trying to go to the same
place. We're all trying to
develop the best strategy to make sure we have the best drug to get to patients
fastest. So we tried to step away from that and said, "Let's just
focus on what we're trying to achieve, and then we'll put it in the reflection
paper that we need to get to a globally agreed
definition." Hopefully, we will.
Thank you.
Also at the FDA, we have a NAM's coordinating committee, and we have
an EMA liaison. So we are in discussion.
And in DHAD, we meet with the EMA non-clinical working
party three times a year, and we are having those discussions,
case studies on NAMs, and et cetera as well.
Going, I don't know who was next.
Thanks for the great panel. I have a comment as a bioinformatician and a
question. The comment I think Matt would agree with me is, maybe think of
something other than NAM as next-gen sequencing is still 20 years old,
and we have other technologies. I don't know.
Maybe we could start calling them as NAM one, NAM two, so there is no
confusion.
The question that I have is, I really like the concept of
this is transitioning towards going away from animal models as
a whole. So as for the panel, I want to ask, what do you think
some of the solutions that can enable that future?
How many ever years after that happens, what would be the
approaches? Because I
think if you're thinking about paradigm shifts, now is the time to discuss that as
opposed to wait until we reach that point and then figure out how do we
enable it.
Yes, go ahead, please.
Okay.
Yes.
I can take that one. Thank you.
So, I think that right now we're even talking about
single NAMs, and how those fit
into
this paradigm, and I really think that in the future, it's going to be an
integrated kind of enterprise platform as we think.
But to get there, I think data is really going to be that enabler, that driver,
and so how do we start to think about capturing that data, unifying that
data, really ensuring that there's standards and there's
access, and that it's interoperable.
And so I think those are things to enable us to get to
that big kind of integrated enterprise that I think we'll
see happening and where AI will be able to play a huge role
there. But we need that human relevant data in a way that we're
confident in the data that we're collecting.
So, similar to kind of TCGA that we've done in the
cancer space, how do we think about that from a NAM's
perspective? Obviously NAMs have a lot of
multiscale data, so it's going to be a different type of platform and integration.
But, I think that's something that if we can push that forward,
we'll be able to see big progress there.
Thank you. Anybody else from the panel wants to?
Yeah, I was just going to add, again, I think Shannon just touched upon it.
It has to be findable, searchable that everybody can do.
Because right now, the way we do it is
with
historical knowledge at the company.
Mm-hmm.
And if that person happened to be around for 20 years, they're the single
source of information. And until we can get that into
a system that everybody can have access to, and
that continues to build, so that, again,
we can start leveraging the clinical data as well as the non-clinical data to see
where it has been predictive, to see where it has not been predictive.
And until we can get that, that is simple for us
non-informational informatics people,
that's the biggest thing. Because right now, one of the challenges
that we have is we have the informatics people, which are doing it, and then
we have the scientists, which are trying to leverage it, and we don't speak the
same language. And so there's a challenge of just communicating of what are
we actually asking for, and then they're asking, "What do you actually need from
us?" And vice versa. So, I think there's just going to be
iterations, but ultimately we want to get out of that, "Oh, it's
on Noelle's computer" type of response.
So I think I
have just an announcement, but we'll be staying another five, 10 minutes to
answer your questions. Thank you.
And I want to thank all the speakers and panelists,
for this session. Wonderful discussions.
Thank you all the audience for such an engaged
audience. Thank you very much. I really appreciate it.
I want to thank AACR, and especially
Brad Davidson, who's been excellent
keeping us on track and everything, and having everything prepared for us,
all the hard copies, et cetera.
So this concludes today's session on the regulatory science and
policy track. Come back here to this room 10:15 a.m.
tomorrow. There is another session, and
that would be led by Lola Farshan Ayah.
The title of this session is Strengthening the Oncology Trial
Ecosystem through Operational and Regulatory
Innovation. Thank you everyone. If you have more questions, we are here to
answer. Thanks.